America's top Diplomat was at church
this Ash Wednesday a Ukrainian Church in
Washington DC a guest of Ukraine's
ambassador to the U.S Oksana mokarova
you're our star
inside Anthony blinken's demeanor was
that of a man who wishes he could do
more if only the risks of escalation
with Russia were not so grave it's in
the most difficult moments that
our faith is tested
this is a difficult moment but I know
that we will you will the Ukrainian
people are showing
they are rising to to the test
all along Pennsylvania Avenue the
Ukrainian flag is flying but across town
at the state department the message was
for the Russian people we know
many of you want no part of this war
you like ukrainians like Americans like
people everywhere want the same basic
things
good jobs
clean air and water
the chance to raise your kids in safe
neighborhoods in New York at the United
Nations an historic vote to condemn
Russia to call for it to pull out of
Ukraine not binding of course but the
message was overwhelming in red with
Russia North Korea Eritrea Syria and
Belarus are Putin's only true friends
among the 34 abstentions perhaps avenues
for diplomacy to end all this China has
said it's engaged with both sides India
too and the ukrainians say it could not
be more urgent
as the President of Ukraine asked
what was the point of repeating this
slogan never again in 80 years
it's already clear that the goal of
Russia is not
an occupation only
it is genocide
the president has now ordered sanctions
on Russia's defense industry and on
Belarus too intentionally targeting
civilian areas there are over 2 000
civilians there they are thank you the
effort to find an end to all this will
continue Mark Stone Sky News in
Washington